hi there this is uh going to be a film
on the can and it's designed to go with
the Boogie woza levels that I
I've now started to introduce to the
world
and it doesn't matter where you are in
the world if you send me a video or if
you're standing in front of me and I'm
testing you these are the uh the weaker
points that most people have and I want
to just go over them with you
and so you can check yourself out before
you either apply and work on them so
that you sharpen your your Aikido
I remember coach Hotel saying Aikido in
daily life you write a book on it and
I'm outside and perhaps my dog my
occasionally decide that she doesn't
like people in the field around us or
walking by so you might hear a
chirp up as well but that's I key down
in daily life okay so let's start
the suburbs are what you should work on
year in year out
and scientistsense he really said that
the suburbies and the Kern tattoos or
the flowering
Ken is just the Cebu is done with
movement so if you can do the Sabu as
well then you're about to do the
attaches the Ken King Sumi no touch
the kentai Joe
and so on
okay so what are the common faults
uh if you do film yourself always film
yourself from the front
side
I'm not worried so much about the the
other side or the back okay so your
chest side if it's sideways being a
chest side is
to my left
because we only ever hold to Ken with
our right hand forward so that's why we
would try if you look left
one of your fists apart
mine are sometimes smaller but it should
be one one hand apart space between you
in the can and a lot of people have got
this finger this what I call we call it
the trigger finger if you watch even the
advanced heat wama teachers they'll um
they'll have this finger in the Ken and
the Joe you know when they ski you can
see it and they're holding the Joe and
they're holding the can since he said
it stands out and if it stands out then
it'll stand out to your partner an
attacker
and it's a little bit like those of you
drive with a car
there might be only one tree in the
whole Road or Telegraph pole in the hole
over the car seems always hit the
telegraph pole of the tree
so it's a little bit like that he said
that the the attacker would use that and
and break that finger because it's
vulnerable
even side her Sensei told us not to do
this
but occasionally I saw him do that and
I'm sure I'm doing things wrong also
even today all right but uh we are here
but I'm telling you the points that you
should work on and correct so that
they're not there
so if it has to have a gap let's have a
look here close that's about the most
Gap that I normally try to allow all
right it doesn't feel right sometimes
just close together but that's where he
told us where it should be he'd shout at
us even but then I'd see him do this
okay
so that's a that's a weakness as well
when cutting
I'll do the upper half first when
cutting
a lot of people their elbows go out like
this
and the elbows you'll notice as I come
here my elbows are much wider than my
shoulders so the idea is to try to keep
the elbows and the arms no wider than
the shoulders
again in the evenings when we used to
chat he said if you can walk through a
door while cutting
then your arms are in the right place he
said you'll never get through the door
like this so it's just something that
has stayed with me all these years
so
if you find that your elbows are going
out just draw them in
on the downward cut
draw them in
on the downed cut
if you can keep them in
then it's good
going to the back leg now
there's different variations
cytosense he said don't lock the leg but
don't have it too
soft or else it's like you're sitting on
a bar stool
this one it looks like you've stopped
and gone down on this bar stool
okay
you're going forwards
so project forward but don't lock it
just a very small
piece
that don't have it bent
you will say
perhaps that I'm contradicting what
you've seen
a student
is with their Scentsy their Master for a
period of years mine was in total 27.
19 followed him twice a year around the
world the other was before I met him
with his early films and his early books
and I would train daily in the evenings
look at the films and I could copy films
better than I could follow the books
so I would watch a piece of film I'd go
in my back garden and I would train the
kennel Joe so 27 years I've been
watching him
over those 27 years he changed
dramatically
and a lot of people don't like teachers
that change dramatically
but we all hopefully are going to
advance so he went from really
one posture almost completely to an
upright posture
well I'm telling you the period that I
saw him in what he told us and and he
was just past the age of 50 then so he
was going in between very powerful stage
and more subtle work and wanting as you
got older still he wanted these points
so I'm trying to give you these points
if you're doing a series of suburbies
I like to see three of each
but don't do this each time you've done
one
for me that that looks a little bit
stupid and robotic okay so start do
Stripe from where you ended
some teachers were in an era where they
stepped first
I I was in there before this
and if you watch sight and Scentsy on
any films check the films don't take my
word for it you see such a city on any
of the films you won't see him stepping
first
the theory is Who Would You Walk
would you step onto a spear before you
have protection if your Ken needs to be
in front of you
if you step first
it gives you stability so if you're
looking for stability then please step
first
so the other problem that we see
[Applause]
person comes here
they turn to cart
and it becomes what I call a dead cat
they they almost just cut on the spot
return
they just cut
it's almost like a dead cut so I shall
be looking to see how much of a cut you
can put in that that is real so
yeah
sleep keep the feet with me together
even if you have to pull one back or
bring one forward
okay the next thing if you do cut on the
opposite side
this side
a lot of people their arms go away from
their Center and it ends up outside
their body so you want to be careful
even you seniors you don't want to be
cutting like that just outside the body
line
this is no good if it was a Joe they
could your partner could take that and
push you and throw you so keep it in
front of your Center Line
remember the elbows
when you're turning to the left the
right the left hand opens
when you're turning to the right
the right hand opens
as soon as it's going to come down you
close the hand
as you come down in the strike the hands
are squeezing as if you're going to ring
out a towel of water you're squeezing
that
the two fingers are the ones that do the
squeezing and the others follow
so these are the points that I need you
to look at
is this Gap too small
is this thing go out
are the elbows too wide
is the back leg to Bent
another point is the head it will look
at times with every teacher that the
head is dead but there's down and
there's too much down
to try to look
forward
not down like this
if you look down
it tells me that you're deep in
concentration and you're not aware of
the surroundings around you
okay
so there's some important points there
that you need to to work on the next one
is the sixth of Brewery with the ski so
to come here
now it's really difficult a lot of
people they just
poke this
becomes a poet there's no power there
so what you need what you want to look
for
is
the cut you can try this both ways if
the Gap is oh not too big then eject
yourself lift the front for a little not
too much and eject yourself forward
the gaps not too big
eject yourself forward
you must have this punch to your sixer
Bowie
the other way that you can do it quite
like this as well but it needs timing
you do this and as soon as the foot
lands you bring the back foot up a
little
Okay so
I'll do it a bit of an angle
project or
[Music]
okay so either the back foot come either
the back foot comes up and the moment
it's coming down the back foot comes the
back foot comes up
you
the power to eject
it mustn't be a poke okay
so when you're raising over the head
the Suburbans the seconds very third
February
and uh
fifth sixth so it starts with this
you know a lot of people this is too low
to their head
if you see my arms bent
they need to really be higher
it's okay having this uh
it's okay having this
but if you want to one day find Coke you
you need what I call Little triggers you
need triggers of inspiration the
inspiration is going to give you the
release one day of coke you so it's like
going up to the heavens you know since
he used to say he he gets from the
heavens and brings it down to earth
and then
you know perhaps you got to believe in a
little bit more than what what you do
regularly Okay so
[Applause]
and then when you cut you've got that
wonderful burst of energy adrenaline or
whatever you'd like to call it
and it makes the cut very powerful
if it's um too low to the head it's all
controlled
the
it's a mechanical dead cut
Okay so
third story I'm jumping around because
there's pieces that I'm covering in a in
a sort of a stage
the Third suburbi
I always say do the first a brewery
all right
when you're halfway through the first
suburbing just switch it into the second
so the first part that comes the same
first
second
hey
first
second
you go from the first to the second to
the Third
first
second now the difference with the third
is
Ken is a little more upright here at
this point the Ken goes upright
go up to the heavens taking
an in-breath now
push it to the pit of your stomach
the hands must be
not everything firmly on the cane but
one has used to say it's like holding
eggs in your hand you mustn't crush them
don't have the end of the can out
because your partner can see it drop it
so that it's behind you
turn come over the head
cut
so this is where you'll be able to look
at all your weaknesses
the next thing I'd like to say is I'll
show you sideways because a lot of
people are what I call in the aggressive
stage and they should be in the neutral
stage with their body
if you're here
you're aggressive because you're looking
forward be here
50 50 50 50.
bring it up
open the foot
strike
thank you
okay so there'll always be more points
that we can add but these are the things
that I should be looking for
in the
in the various stages so for those who
wish to send in a film or as I say being
funny
smaller Gap I'm not too worried about
but one hand length finger
keep it as close as you can
elbows mustn't be out
and doing the fifth you have to
concentrate all the time on the elbows
it's no good
and then bringing them in let's start
somewhere start bringing them in on the
downward swings and once you get a
better Rhythm they'll become natural
the sevenths of Birdie
I'm not going to say much about that
because it's just the body timing and
again it's a punch from your your Center
all right so I hope these things will
help you
study and you can always ask me
questions on messenger
email there's lots of ways of contacting
you now if you're aren't still unsure
okay I hope you've enjoyed this film and
the next one I'll try and make will be
on the Joe
don't worry
ah one small Point sorry
I noticed the other day that someone
offered the the Ken like this to the
showman and bound you should never do
that first all the blade should be to
you the handle on the left the blade
should be to you because you're bound to
the oh Scentsy or the teacher and you're
saying I trust you if you want to cut me
it's up to you the handle's on there
right
okay but the hands should never be this
way up fist up it should always be this
offering
is a way to do it
if I'm going to hand it to someone
the Blade is to me I hand them it they
open their hands they take it I'll
pretend that uh they're the opposite
person now so now they've received it
they take it and they roll the blade
straight back to them face them that
means that thank you and I trust you I
think so it's it's it's
a one of the biggest thing which we must
have in
okay so it's the small points and thank
you for your time